ce matin les pompiers qui ont débuté
hier des recherches la zone en parallèle
avec les gendarmes sont à nouveau
mobilisés
plusieurs plaisanciers et les amis de la
famille d'un disparu
participent à ces opérations de
recherche nous reprenons les recherches
et l'objectif en fait c'est coordonner
nos moyens avec les autres services qui
sont chargés de cette mission à l'appui
de l'hélicoptère de la gendarmerie le
griffon plusieurs unités
ce coût est à nouveau ce plan d'eau de
lens madame h el cheikh
l'opération mobilise l'hélicoptère de la
section aérienne comme vous avez pu le
voir passer de manière nous aider sur
les recherches et notamment à essayer de
resserrer au maximum la zone de
recherches est également on assure sur
l'eau une équipe de la brigade nautique
qui est en charge de plonger sur ce que
pourrait déceler éventuellement
l'hélicoptère ou sûr en fonction des
zones de recherche qui nous sont
assignées
daisy hier en fin d'après midi les
recherches ont été orientés par rapport
à des signalements en fait
l'intervention s'est passé en deux temps
sec en laye dans un premier temps un
témoignage qui nous indiquait quelque
chose de suspect en mer donc
l'hélicoptère est sorti pour aller à les
vérifier et en parallèle donc on a eu le
signalement d'une disparition de
personnes donc après on reste prudent
sur le sur les rapprochements puisque on
est quand même sur une
on est sur une phase où tous les
éléments sont importants ça nous a
permis d'avoir une zone de recherche qui
n'a été déterminée par un pêcheur
la difficulté maintenant c'est des
courants qui sont très forts et
surtout qu'ils sont changeants pour
l'heure aucune trace de ces deux dames
habitué à la baignade dans ce secteur
les investigations se poursuivent
aucune piste n'est écartée